we need fresh thinking on the cause of
and the solution to the unemployment
crisis both in Europe but also beyond
because ultimately all the countries
currently sharing the same banking
system it's a banking system where the
money in circulation is created as debt
by banks at interest so it means that
when there's a crisis in confidence then
the bank stop lending and as money is
debt that's how it was created suddenly
there's a lot less money in the economy
that means there's less money for people
to buy stuff it's less money to invest
less money for wages and for jobs and so
that is the key cause of rising
unemployment in most economies right now
it's not that suddenly people are less
skilled all that there's to suddenly be
less demand it's actually a function of
the monetary system and so although many
people are saying right now we need to
just look at solving the euro crisis
quickly that shouldn't be an argument
for staying away from looking at some of
the deeper problems in the current
monetary system we need to look at
whether this non pretty much non reserve
banking system that we've got at the
moment and the way that governments
can't raise money other than through
selling bonds so they can't issue their
own earn money whether this really is a
sustainable monetary system whether this
is a desirable monetary system for our
multiple interests names whether that's
full employment whether it's less
inequality more environmental
sustainability and so on so we need to
listen to unorthodox economists about
monetary systems and military redesign
and we need to start looking at various
different policy measures that could be
used in the UK where I'm from there's a
campaign called positive money and they
have drafted some legislation that they
would like to be discussed about
basically moving to full reserve banking
and restoring the ability of the
government to issue its own
currency and I'm that that isn't it like
a criticism of one currency over another
because all currencies today seem to be
issued as debt by banks so you know they
call it the euro the dollar the pound
whatever ultimately it's the same
technology of money with same system of
money in that it's created as credit by
banks but what I work on isn't that
because that's obviously quite a complex
issue and it's going to take one all the
time and a lot of a lot of people with a
lot more knowledge than I i have on
economics and monetary issues so what I
work on is providing communities and
small businesses with alternative
systems for exchange right now so
there's a small NGO in Switzerland that
I'm on the board of Claude community
Forge and we provide free open-source
software for communities to exchange
amongst themselves so it's like a
alternative currency system and those
those those communities are benefiting
from the fact that if they are cash poor
they can still do stuff for each other
and they have this alternative way of
monitoring that accounting for that so
it's it's a form of currency we call it
mutual credit and so this is growing now
and we're looking at ways of rolling
this out for for companies as well and
we're working with banks or like a
not-for-profit bank in the United States
on this and how it could be applied for
businesses so there needs to be clearly
a lot of creative thinking financial
innovation trial and error in this space
and we need altima tlie to end up with
sustainable currencies that will enable
a fair and more stable and more
sustainable economy locally nationally
and ultimately worldwide so this is the
kind of thing I'm talking to people hear
about in the corridors some some of
these issues are coming out slightly in
the plenaries but generally we've still
got a long way to go for understanding
and really intelligent discussions about
monetary systems monetary reform and
also complementary alternatives
like the systems that I'm involved in so
hopefully that's giving you some
slightly different take on the the
underlying cause of mass unemployment
the and the need to actually have some
new ideas about solving it